and we know golden knights playoff games
always draw a huge crowd and when you
add major Construction in and around
T-Mobile Arena it can be a recipe for
disaster Sasha Loftus spoke with
Pete Tropicana tonight and joins us live
with more on some upcoming closures that
you can expect Sasha
Denise and Brian we are all way too
familiar with the Tropicana project
right but on nights like this after a
big night's playoff game this major
construction causes even more problems
so we drove through and checked it out
once we saw that that red on our Google
Maps we're like yeah no thanks dealing
with the Maze We call Tropicana parts of
the I-15 and Tropicana have been a mess
for months now as Crews continue the
long-term construction project to revamp
and widen the area we always try to
avoid it when we can game five is
underway but you add a golden knights
playoff game and those normal traffic
tie-ups become a nightmare
those we spoke with say getting through
was anything but easy sometimes they
have a detour so you got to go the other
way so we headed out on the roads
affected including Tropicana Dean Martin
and of course the I-15 itself
some spots feel like the delays will
never end but that's why those we spoke
with say they do what they can to plan
ahead we took a look at it and we jumped
off we got on the side roads and make it
to all the amazing events like this in
the Vegas Zone our city has to offer
now the next side street closure to
watch for associated with Tropicana is
the eastbound site of Harmon from
Polaris to the Vdara that starts on May
15th and it should last through
September of course in addition to all
the other closures we're seeing in the
area reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus
8 News Now